c'est dans ce laboratoire que j'ai
découvert les tortues nous avons erré
dans les égouts jusqu'à ce que je trouve
cet endroit mais c'est alors que le
mutagènes qui avaient été ajoutées dans
notre sens c'est bien de transformer mes
fils vous serez des légendes
donne cet appareil photo hall et rocades
non ma carapace va être la télé c'est
quoi le nez des ninjas sur le papier on
est des portiers tortues ninja vous êtes
des frères vivent et combattez mourrez
comme des frères mais je ne vous ai pas
préparé à ça vous fait quoi
j'suis une tortue alligator béraud
je
après qu'est ce que tu fabriques
immiscée petit pont d'hérault
focus sur les toits non c'est cool mais
lui continue surtout change rien
la peur détruira ce monde les gars je ne
sens pas
s'en serait juste à l'angle